[音楽]
諏訪市
みなさんこんにちは石も色です影響はですね
グローバル企業って何だろうということをお話しさせてください
ちょっとネタバレなんですけども私はの今仲間たちとこの五反田でグローバル9を作る
べき
べく日々奮闘しますそんな中で考えていることとかあっあっていることというのを今日
皆さん
シャーシ
ていただきたいというふうに思います
その前ですよ私はまあなんでそんなことやる方に至ってるのかっていうのを知って
いただくために
私のバックグラウンド
説明させていただきたいと思います42%を
私ですねー
過去私の人生における時間の42%海外で生活しているんですね
最近このパーセント減ってまして1者の60%恋した時があるんですけども
子供この親の仕事でドイツという国は9人ぐらいその後は自分しかいない
入っていると
学校計でない大画面化に残念外
その後はなんと仕事でですね中南米
なかなか馴染みのない国が入っていました生とかですね
メキシコとか
あの就職して2年目で結構乱暴な会社だったら
中山に行ってもいいということで私もその最初の仕事もほとんどが中が命だと
仕事をしてきましたけれど早いまし
これが私のこれまでのキャリアです
最初ですね大企業を詰め4 elsa 大企業に入りまして仕事をしました
でその後仕事を変えるたびにまあ7217人で最後には11人ということでかなり小屋
も心配しているかの状態なんですけれども大丈夫です私的には小さくなればなるほど
楽しい
hey
いうことで大企業からという中企業で今は小企業まずまさにスタートアップ
仕事をしている
で凝視も業界のバラバラでして最初はの製造量ですね
で次が金融そしてコンサルを得て今 it 企業機ってやっている職種も最初はの営業
マーケティング系のセールスマン家からスタートしまして
ゲー企画をやって
次今されれば事業機会の開発をやりつつ今まぁ全部ということで
社長というポジション電話企業を経営させていただけるとここなキャリアを歩んでい
ます
[音楽]
here もちろん製品として僕は見たところ
あるんですけど高校の時にえ
ずアメリカに留学していてかなり田舎に留学したんですけどその時のお友達がいいです
ね
ウォールマートがなんかの買い物行って大熊同棲みたいな話になった時にずーっと
ソニーのアメリカの会社で言い張ってですね
ではね日本じゃなかった毛って思ってやったんですけど結局最後まで1回は譲れば制し
た
それぐらいなんですからアメリカ人にとっても自分の国の会社と思っちゃうくらいの
会社なんですねその2
でその後ソニーに入りまして
に眠り
はなまというふうに仲裁にてこいということでまぁさっさと僻地に飛ばされまして
パナマという国に駐在しますと見ているマーケットが
結果中米のですね
んじゃないかもしれないけどコスタリカとか
許されば鳥とかそんなのなかなか行かないの国に出張に加えんですね
イミグレでまんまと止められまして
何しに来たしっ
市から日本のパスポートを持ってるけどちょっと顔がインド人ぽくないかなって
余計なお世話てるのでそもそもですねまぁ結構を疑われたぽいんですね
でそこで困ってですねや
僕はソニーという会社に働いていて今回市場調査に来たんというとそのおじさんがリス
や内村ににこあるぞと
指どおりを削ぎいる俺はその2雷好きだっていう風に言われまして
を勝つ凄い凄い会社に働いてるなーってその時すごい実感したんですね
って振り返ってみるとあの中央東ですとかお金の駐在員さんとか見ていってもやっぱり
そうにって特殊で自分の調子が外国人だったりとか
ええもう意味だ言っているわけです
なので他の会社さんみると結構やっぱり日本人が来て日本人がマネージメントして仕事
をすると
それいくら米とソニーというのは本当にダイナミックなグローバルな会社だったかな
そこに私の社会としての限定になります
って私は細いを卒業したあとやっぱり海外に関わる仕事がしたいということでまぁ
が意外に中小企業今の日本の中小企業さ d 商売をされている e 術を持っており
患者さんを出していくのを手伝いたいという風でパティコンサートしてやらして
もらおう
してい
結構大変でしたね
8ですね何が絶えないかってやっぱり人がいないんですよ
で海外行きましょうこのニックに行きましょうってさ長さんとか
マネジメント一緒に決めるんですけども実際一緒に行って動いてくれる人がいてそこ
からスタートしなきゃいけないです
というところとあとその後にできますけれども
毎度セット要は会社として本気でグローバルマーケットとっていこうと思っているか
どうか
結構多いのが甘い奥歯いきたいなぐらいですね
そうするとやっぱり警備ソースも入るんですとか
もう地道に何連1年2年海外が出るわけないと思うんですけども
それはやり続けるだけの前のセットやっぱり会社にないというところを痛感して
で計10社ぐらいお手伝いさせてもらってるんですけどもなかなかなかなか苦戦しまし
た
じゃあ弾起用ってどうなんだろうちょっと見ていたんですね
でこれは上場企業って海外進出している比率
なんと上場してても半分くらいしかまだかいな叶えべーションしないというのが現状
です
でその中で it 企業もフィリス動画もっていうと
6%しかないですねほとんどが製造量とか
流通
なので日本で日以来日本で成功しているグローバル it きよっては非常に少ないと
いうことです
でこれが驚異的ですね
日本の大企業さんの日本本社にいる外国人の社員比率
なんと一番前
取締役
一人でも取締役がいる iq 海外の方がいる比率っていうのは2%着てい
では98%の会社さんは一人参らないですね
なかなかこれはないのが高いなと
で中にはあのヘッドポーターの日本の紅葉を英語にして
英語でコミュニケーションをとりましょうって言っている会社さんもいますそういった
会社さんに打ち合わせるいってですね
日本人10人で外国の方一人の君の一生懸命をしゃべって皆黙ってみたいな
これはどうなんだろうというふうに結構疑問思いましたん
そんな中で私がちょっといろいろ考えまして
じゃあグローバルカンパニーって何だろうどうやったのグローバルカンパニーができる
んだろうと
じゃあ自分でやってみようということでしまってこのもう日ですという会社でですね
これをグローバル it カンパニーしようというふうに頑張っておりますまだの表れ
のデイサービスあは日本語に入って海外に出て行っておりませんちょっとずつ死んで
いるんですね100人くらい紹介します
でその100人なんですけどもまぁ既に30パー弱が今外国人の方
って役員
25%が速い上の人でやってもらっています
ブーバしたにょている海外のみなさんですね日本マティ
あるんですねなのでもう日本語で通してやりましょう
ただいろいろサポートは互いにし会いましょうということで
先ず一つがそのいろんな国のいろんな考えを持った人たちと一緒に働くので何が我々に
とってのバリューなんかどういうことを考えながら働いていくんだろうというものは
結構明確に打ち出すということですね
corporate バリッというものをしっかり作って言っています
パターン先ほど日本語でやろうということに決めたんですけどもまぁ
1やてぃともいるわけでまあそういった人たちですねっお互いに支え合いながらてぃ
わからなければ教えてもらえばいいじゃないということで女性当たらないですね
なのでちょっとは変えなければ他の言語で支援をしてあげると
こういった形ではのいろんな国の人が映画国も言葉を喋りながら6州で日仕事をして
いくって仕事だけじゃなくてですね
いろんな部活みたいな待って
楽しみながらやっている
こういったことを創生してやっております
ただか哀れ here の方等よろしくマネージメントというものなんですけどあー
ヌーです私このよし
9マネジメントはソニー最初の駐在のかなというふうに3年くらい入ってたんですけど
もそこで自分の部下に教えてもらいました
駐在した時の最初が26歳ぐらいだったんですね
あー8はまだ若造でいきなりあの
30人ぐらいチームを任されて全員自分より年上で私の前任者10歳ぐらいウェイ
いきなり7こいつっていう空気感の中で仕事からスタートしました
here till なったことがあります
はい
としないですよね
でそんな中である日ですね
あの私その時あの直営店っていうかお店をやっている舞台を見ていたので
ショッピングモールの中に
お店だったんですねでその店のオーナーさんからまず連絡がありまして今までの8
チップ1.5倍にさせてくれと
ちょっと相場が変わったからとポーンときてですね
を見せられている方わかるかもしれないんですけど
入ってご前のやつに当てはめるわけないんですね
そうすると出るしかっ
でも出るにしても新しいお店作ってすごいお金はかかる
これは困ったとっていう時にですね自分のチームメンバーの中に
華僑の人がいます
華僑系パナマ人行きですね
でそのショッピングのローナーも書をなっています
でポンと言われたのか
華僑が佳境話した方が話が通じるから俺が入ってくるっていうふうに入って行ってきて
くれないでしょ
やらしもまあその通り任せられるのかなと思いながらお願いをしたんですけれども
なんとですね
って家賃を維持するどころか下げて帰ってきたですね
ねこれはさすがだなとよくやった中でその時なんかさーっと自分が娯楽になったって
いうか
自分じゃなくていいんだっていうのを持ったですね
僕より優秀な人が散りうんってでやってくれれば
これってをこの結果にもあるんだって当たり前のことがそこで貼って渡って
めちゃくちゃなくなりましょうそこからはよろしくマルモニョロシクルッって投げて
行ってもらったティ学んで
メキシコでもやってみてアメリカでなっている2名をするんですよ
グローバル会社の技術の栄養軒思ってまして我々経営陣一同マネージャー一度この
よろしくマネジメントやって来ずということでこれを武器にですね海岸に戦っていき
たいというふうに思います
で7色今作もやって自分で会社も得ながら思ったところはすべては枚のセットという
ふうに思いました
会社がグローバーなっていく実はその解説体をグローバーになるという気概がなけれ
絶対行かないと思いますね
あと a
海外に行くためには日本人だろうが何柱になるのが一切関係なくてその仕事に対して
ベストな人にお願いしてよろしくと言って行ってもらうっていうのがある
これしかないという風に考えてましてまあ全てマイロセンターからスタートするという
風に考えます
ん
なので今はれはないですねこの前の窃盗をもっとに先ほど観ていただいたように30%
ぐらい人ももうすでに
外国人構成されていてしかも海外で胸張って言える
勝てる商材をしっかり作って
グローバル r 4 r 2 s ねぶーろーばー at ようになっている多いと
いう気持ちでぜひあっていますこれは一部のメンバーですけど今ぬーっ聞いてやってる
んじゃなくてもビルスの m という言葉ってはいこっからすぐのところにお店があり
ますのでよろしければ是非
遊びに来てください今日どうもありがとうございました